bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat à suivre cet après-midi
dans l'hémicycle la discussion d'une
proposition de résolution qui vise à
améliorer les la condition des
ressortissants roumains et bulgares à
mes côté pour en parler al archambau
sénatrice Europe Écologie et les veres
de scè Saint-Denis bonjour alors vous
êtes à l'origine de cette proposition de
résolution hier un décret est paru au
Journal officiel qui donc permet un
accès un meilleur accès un élargissement
de l'accès à l'emploi des ressortissants
roumains et bulgares c'est ce que vous
demandiez en partie est-ce que vous avez
obtenu gain de cause je me félicite bien
évidemment de cette décision du
ministère du travail et du ministère de
l'Intérieur je pense qu'elle va tout à
fait dans le bon sens sens et je m'en
réjouis et il me semble que justement
c'est c'est l'occasion que le Sénat on
verra s'il me suit aujourd'hui dans son
vote etmettre le souhait que
définitivement on lève ce qu'on appelle
les mesures transitoires qui de fait
c'est ce que nous avons vu dans les
auditions que nous avons organisé de
fait bloque presque totalement l'accès à
un emploi légal donc à un revenu légal
pour les ressortissants bulgares et
roumains et uniquement pour ces
ressortissants européens-là et parmi eux
il y a des gens en situation de grande
précarité notamment des Romes et et je
pense qu'il faut en finir avec cela et
donc il serait assez logique après cette
très bonne décision du gouvernement euh
qu'on en finisse aussi avec les mesures
transitoires qui de fait dans ces
conditions présenteent surtout des
aspects négatifs parce qu'elle demande
aux servicees administratifs des
contrôles longs pour établir les
autorisations de travail elles
ralentissent tout et et de fait elles
compromettent la signature des contrats
de travail il faut immédiatement après
si c'était fait voir les question
d'hébergement qui sont évidemment très
fortes et là aussi je pense qu'on peut
trouver une mobilisation forte parmi les
association parmi les citoyens roumains
et bulgares eux-mêmes qui ne demandent
pas la charité qui sont prêts à se
mobiliser par exemple dans des campagnes
d'autoconstruction et nous devons
demander des financements européens la
France peut demander des cofinancements
européens peut demander à s'appuyer sur
les régions peut demander à tout ce que
font aujourd'hui déjà un certain nombre
d'élus locaux qui se sentent bien seul
parce que tous les efforts qu'ils font
en matière de santé d'hébergement
d'accès à l'école à un moment donné sont
bloqués parce que les les les personnes
qui sont accueillies dans leur
dispositif ne trouvent pas d'emploi et
donc n'ont pas de ressources légales et
sans accès à des ressources légales on a
une situationù ils sont rejetés dans
l'illégalité c'est-à-dire le travail
illégal et tout ce qui va avec et ça
n'est pas bon uneéaction à la politique
menée par Manuel vas le ministre de
l'Intérieur sur le démantellement des
camps de Rome il a dit fermeté il avait
même dit la France ne veut pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde
reprenant les propos de Michel Rocard je
pense c'est que tout est lié euh moi
aussi je suis pour la disparition des
bidonville et bien entendu contre les
trafic les mafias en tout genre mais si
on veut arriver à une à une av une base
objective pour régler les problèmes il
faut que ces populations aient les mêmes
droits que tous les autres Européens les
Hongrois les Polonais les Italiens les
Portugais en France ont un accès au
travail légal dans certaines conditions
il faut que les Roumains et les Bulgares
aient les mêmes droits pas plus pas de
privilège mais pas moins et avoir des la
possibilité de ressources légal de
revenus légal c'est le début d'une
possibilité d'intégration et donc après
d'une mobilisation sur les autres
problèmes qui existent en effet très
fort hébergement santé éducation tout de
suite donc direction l'hémicycle pour
suivre ce débat bon après-midi à
tous l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen de
la proposition de loi relative au
ressortissant de nationalités roumaines
et Bulgar présenté en application de
l'article 341 de la Constitution par
madame Aline archimbaau et les membres
du groupe écologiste dans le débat la
parole est à madame Aline archimbaau
auteur de la proposition de résolution
vous avez la parole ma cher
collègue monsieur le
Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers
collègues lors de mon arrivée au Sénat
l'année dernière j'ai souhaité commencer
un travail de fond concernant la
situation de certains de nos concitoyens
européens des ressortissants roumains et
bulgares et parmi eux les plus précaires
économiquement communément désignés
comme Rome bien que tous n'appartiennent
pas au peuple Rome mon expérience d'élus
local m'avait amené à être témoin des
conditions de vie misérables dans
lesquelles beaucoup d'entre eux vivent
ou plutôt survivent et des préjugés dont
ils sont victimes dans la société
française européenne et qui débouche sur
bon nombre de discriminations et de
mauvais traitements cette situation m'a
paru indigne de notre République j'ai
donc pris contact avec les acteurs de
terrain engagés à leur côté association
et ONG élus et simples citoyens mais
également avec des ressortissants
roumains et bulgares car on ne fait pas
bien pour les gens qu'avec eux ceci afin
de mieux comprendre quels étaient les
obstacles et difficultés rencontrer au
quotidien et d'identifier les leviers à
actionner afin de permettre une bonne
intégration de ces population tous ont
répondu présent et je souhaite les en
remercier chaleureusement ainsi que
saluer amicalement ceux qui sont
présents aujourd'hui dans les tribunes
sans eux ce travail n'aurait pas été
possible nous avons donc organiser à
partir de novembre 2011 des réunions de
travail au Sénat et des déplacements
dans plusieurs régions dans les
campements illégaux sur les terrains
conventionnés dans les dispositifs
d'insertion afin de prendre la pleine
mesure de la situation la direction de
l'initiative au Sénat a organisé des
auditions et je la remercie pour la
qualité du travail qu'elle a accompli
nous avons donc entendu les responsables
nationaux mais aussi locaux de la
plupart des grandes associations qui
interviennent sur le terrain association
de défense des droits de l'Homme
association de solidarité de de lutte
contre la pauvreté association de
médecins humanitaires nous avons
également entendu de nombreux élus
locaux de toute couleur politique des
responsables administratifs et des
concitoyens roumains et bulgares tous
soulignent les situations d'errance
permanentees qui posent de graves
problèmes d'accès aux soins le terme
d'urgence sanitaire a été martelé par
les médecins auditionnés et on peut
également lire le rapport de
l'Observatoire Régional de Santé
d'île-de-fance intitulé situation
sanitaire et sociale des Romes migrants
en Île-de-France et qui est
malheureusement très très clair sur
cette question et beaucoup d'autres
difficultés difficultés de scolarisation
et bien d'autres vous le savez
permettez-moi une brève parenthèse
historique l'histoire des tiganes et des
Romes est faite depuis de nombreux
siècles de réduction en esclavage de
stigmatisation de exécution allant
jusqu'à l'extermination par le régime
nazi sur 1 million de personnes dites
Tsiganes vivant en Europe à la fin des
années 1930 et plus spécialement en
Europe de l'Est entre 25 à 50 % furent
tués pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
et beaucoup déportés à achwitz yasonovak
bourenwald aujourd'hui encore les Romes
sont victimes de discrimination dans
leur pays d'origine mais également dans
leur pays de résidence les préjugés sont
ten envers cette population soupçonnée
de se livrer à des actes de délinquence
de se complaireire dans l'inactivité et
de vivre des aides social or les Romes
présents en France sont le plus souvent
des migrants économiques que la très
grande précarité a poussé à quitter leur
pays d'origine les témoignages
recueillis lors des auditions qui ont
précédé l'élaboration de cette
proposition ont fait ressortir de façon
très convergente leur volonté de trouver
un emploi pour souvenir à leur besoin et
de scolariser leurs enfants à l'opposé
de la vision culturaliste développée par
certains qui postulent que les Romes ne
souhaitent ni travailler ni s'intégrer
par ailleurs la méfiance envers ces
populations est également confortée par
l'idée d'une arrivée massive de Rome en
France or leur nombre sur le territoire
français reste stable depuis le début
des années 2000 il est comparativement
faible environ 15000 à 20000 Rome
maximum viv sur tout le territoire
toutes les estimations convergent sur ce
point très majoritairement de
nationalités roumaines et bulgares les
Romes vivantes en France doivent
surmonter donc un très nombre
d'obstacles au premier rang desquels
nous est apparu que figurent les mesures
transitoires des traités d'adhésion de
la Roumanie et de la Bulgarie à l'Union
européenne signé en 2007 en effet bien
que citoyens d'un d'un pays membre de
l'Union européenne il ne disent dispose
pas aujourd'hui des mêmes droits que les
autres ressortissants européens en
France en matière d'emploi alors que
tous les autres ressortissants européens
peuvent avoir accès au marché de travail
français dans les mêmes conditions que
citoyens français les Roumains et les
bulgare reste assujettis en matière
d'accès à l'emploi aux mêmes obligations
que les étrangers non communautaires
souhaitant travailler en France être en
possession d'un titre de séjour et
obtenir une autorisation de travail les
textes communautaires autoris pour les
pays qui le souhaitent le maintien de
telles mesur jusque fin
2013 la Haute autorité de lutte contre
les discrimination et pour l'égalité a
critiqué cette situation dans sa
délibération numéro 2009 372 du 26
octobre 2009 en soulignant je cite
depuis l'adhésion de la Bulgarie et de
la Roumanie à l'Union européenne les
ressortissants de ces états ne sont ni
considérés comme les autres
communautaires ni comme des migrants non
communautaires l'adhésion de la Roumanie
et de la Bulgarie a permis à partir du
1er janvier 2007 au ressortissant de ces
deux pays comme de tout citoyen ou
toutes citoyenne de l'union de pouvoir
bénéficier je cite du droit de circuler
ou de séjourner librement sur le
territoire des États-membres la
directive européenne
200438 restreint cette liberté tout
citoyen de l'Union a le droit de
séjourner sur le territoire d'un autre
état- membre pour une durée de plus de 3
mois s'il dispose pour lui et pour les
membres de sa famille de ressources
suffisantes afin de ne pas devenir une
charge pour le système d'assistance
sociale de l'état-membre au cours de son
séjour et s'il dispose d'une assurance
maladie complète dans l'État membre
d'accueil or les délais que nous avons
constatés dans les auditions que nous
avons organisé et dans les témoignages
que nous avons euh récoltés nous font
constater que pour l'obtention de de de
de ces autorisations les délais sont
très longs et souvent ce que nous avons
constaté dans notre travail ce sont des
délais qui vont au-delà de 5 6
quelquefois jusqu'à 9 mois ce qui
évidemment
décourage décourage les
employeurs chers
collègues depuis quelques mois le le
contexte national sur cette question a
beaucoup changé et je m'en réjouis le 22
août dernier monsieur le Premier
ministre a présidé une réunion de
travail à laquelle neuf ministres ont
participé il a clairement été rappelé
que c'est une question d'humanité et de
respect des principes fondateurs de la
République qui appelle à traiter de
façon égale et digne toute personne en
situation de difficulté sociale un
certain nombre de mesures extrêmement
positives ont été prises suppression de
la taxe due par l'employeur à l'office
français de l'immigration et de
l'intégration mise en place d'une
mission de coordination de différents
ministères concernés et d'interface avec
le monde associatif auprès du Premier
ministre et il y a 4 jours le 11 octobre
les ministères de l'Intérieur et du
travail ont annoncé que la liste des
métiers autorisé pour les Roumains et
les Bulgares en France sans principe
d'opposabilité va être élargie de 150 à
à
281 dans des secteurs notamment où les
employeurs peinent aujourd'hui à recru
la diminution de toutes ces restrictions
va dans le bon sens et bien sûr nous
nous en
félicitons mais justement dans ces
conditions à quoi bon surcharger les les
les administrations et les services qui
ont déjà forte àire par ailleurs on le
sait pour le contrôle d'une liste qui
est désormais très élargie et pour le
maintien d'une norme en quelque sorte
qui ne présente à mon avis plus aucun
avantage mais qui en revanche bloque
l'accès à un revenu légal et dans ces
conditions nous semble-t-il il vaut
mieux aller jusqu'au bout et simplifier
la
procédure chers collègues il faut sortir
de cette situation absurde absurde sur
un plan financier l'aide au retour
humanitaire coûte ce sont les chiffres
officiels 3 millions d'euros par an à
notre pays sans compter les frais de
fonctionnement dont je n'ai pas pu
trouver les sommes mais qui sont à mon
avis importante 3 million d'euros par an
et c'est une mesure je le dis
objectivement je le constate
objectivement totalement inefficace qui
ne règle rien puisque les Roumains et
les Bulgares peuvent revenir librement
sur notre territoire ils sont européens
de plus s'ils avaient accès librement au
marché du travail ce serait autant de
cotisation social qui tomberaiit dans
les caisses de
l'État cette situation est également
absurde me semble-t-il sur un plan
économique certes la France est en
situation de crise économique grave et
de chômage massif préoccupant mais nous
parlons ici environ de 5000 adultes dans
des corps de métiers dont beaucoup
manque cruellement de main d'œuvre
actuellement et et donc pour beaucoup
des métiers non
concurrentiels alors on argera aussi du
risque d'un appel d'air je n'ai pas vu
d'appel d'air ni en Italie pays qui a
suspendu ses restrictions ses mesures
territoire ces mesures de restriction
fin 2011 il y aura bientôt 1 an ni en
Irlande pays qui les a suspendu il y a
environ un mois ni dans les 19 autres
pays qui les ont déjà suspendus
puisqu'il ne reste plus que que 7 pays
pays qui ont maintenu ces mesures et le
18 novembre
2008 la Commission européenne a rendu
public un rapport sur sur je cite les
effets de la libre circulation des
travailleurs élargis au nouveaux membres
de l'Union européenne ce rapport ne
concluait à aucun impact négatif
significatif sur les salaires sur les
emplois locaux sur les finances
publiques ou sur les systèmes de
protection sociale des pays d'accueil
d'autre part si nous voulons construire
l'Europe quelles que soient les
difficultés nous ne pouvons pas admettre
qu'il existe longtemps des concitoyens
européens de seconde catégorie qui
auraient moins de droit que les autres
ce n'est pas une bonne base pour
construire l'Union européenne la
Roumanie et la Bulgarie sont en France
les deux seuls pays sur les 24 autres
pour lesquels ces mesures de dérogation
ont été demandé par la France et la
rciprocité n'existe pas un citoyen
français en Roumanie ou en Bulgarie n'a
pas à demander une autorisation spéciale
de travail alors soyons clair chacun
doit assumer ses responsabilités et dans
cette situation il y a une triple
responsabilité celle des gouvernements
roumains et bulgares qui doivent prendre
les mesures de faire cesser les
discriminations et les persécutions à
l'égard des Romes celle de l'Union
européenne qui doit veiller à ce que les
fonds européens et ils sont très
importants ils sont très importants que
ces fonds européens qui sont destinés à
financer des projets d'intégration de
ces populations dans toute l'Europe
qu'il soi bien utilisés à cela et est
distribué en toute transparence et nous
en avons aussi besoin en France mais
troisièmement il y a aussi la
responsabilité de la France qui ne peut
pas se défausser et qui doit permettre
un accueil digne à nos concitoyens
lorsqu'ils sont sur notre territoire il
n'y a aucune particularité ethnique
raciale génétique
qui empêcherait les Romes de s'intégrer
les auditions tous les témoignages des
acteurs de terrain que nous avons reçu
tous le confirme dans la majorité des
cas ces populations montrent des formes
extraordinaires de solidarité de courage
de fierté une farouche volonté de
s'intégrer et de réel talent on compte
parmi eux des musiciens célèbres des
artistes et bien d'autres qui ont réussi
savez-vous que la jeune fille qui a reçu
ici même au Sénat en mars 2012 la
médaille d'or des apprentis de France
des meilleurs apprentis de France est
une jeune fille Rome qui avait été
scolarisée un peu moins de 5 ans avant
comme dans tous les bidonvillees comme
dans toutes les favelas du monde on
trouve aussi parmi eux une fraction très
minoritaire de comportement délinquants
voire criminel il n'y a aucune
complaisance à avoir avec ces réseaux
bien sûr mais leur existence ne peut
servir de prétexte à ne pas avancer par
ailleurs avec la grande majorité de
cette population si les mesures
transitoires sont levées ce sera
l'aboutissement d'un processus engagé
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement ce sera
la possibilité pour tous les roumains et
bulgares présents en France de
rechercher un travail légal et donc
d'avoir des ressources légales ce sera
un signal fort aussi pour tous les
réseaux qui se battent à leur côté et
qui sont prêts à engager une dynamique
positive d'intégration permettre un
travail légal et donc un revenu légal
sera la base objective pour pour mettre
un en œuvre un plan d'intégration qui
permette aussi de traiter le problème de
l'hébergement et donc la disparition des
bidon ville source de tension sociale et
terro des mafias et des réseaux
d'exploitation ce sera la fin d'une
discrimination en France entre les pays
européens une discrimination qui n'a
aucun sens aujourd'hui aucune efficacité
ce sera l'établissement des mêmes droits
pour tous nos concitoyens européens sur
le territoire français notre pays est
confronté aujourd'hui à de grands défis
3 millions de chômeurs 7 millions de
précaires la nécessité d'un immense
effort pour relancer l'économie
l'industrie et faire face à une grave
crise international il ne peut se
permettre d'être divisé par des tensions
inutiles chers collègues en votant cette
résolution en souhaitant la levée
maintenant de ces mesures transitoires
le Sénat peut peser dans le bon sens
dans le débat public sa voix pèse vous
le savez en faisant cette proposition je
ne suis pas dans l'angélisme comme vous
je suis attachée à la disparition des
boudonvillees je suis contre le travail
illégal contre la mendicité agressive et
contre la surexploitation des enfants
pour la poursuite et la répression des
trafics en tout genre mais je constate
que le système des mesures transitoires
bloque aujourd'hui l'accès à un droit
normal c'est-à-dire à un travail à un
revenu légal il bloque aussi
réglementairement les postes d'insertion
les postes d'apprentissage les postes en
alternance l'accès à la formation de
droits commun et donc il il l'empêche de
créer une base objective pour dépasser
la situation et pour aborder évidemment
les autres questions importantes qui
sont celles notamment de l'hébergement
de la santé et de la scolarisation je
demande pour les Roumains et les
Bulgares les mêmes droits que pour les
autres citoyens européens sur le
territoire français donnons-leur les
mêmes droits d'accès au revenus pas plus
mais pas moins nous ne demandons aucun
privilège spécial pour eux simplement
une égalité des droits le meilleur moyen
de de permettre de lutter contre toutes
les pratiques illégales c'est de donner
cette égalité et pour terminer je
voudrais rapidement rappeler les récents
événement par exemple à Marseille il
nous appelle chers collègues à faire
preuve de responsabilité des habitants
d'un quartier très pauvre de Marseille
s'en sont pris à un campement Rome sont
allés brûler les affaires et vous savez
bien que cela aurait pu dégénérer
beaucoup plus gravement ces tensions
entre groupes d'habitants en difficulté
les uns et les autres sont inquiétantes
on le sait des tensions du même type
existent dans d'autres villes les élus
les parlementaires les pouvoirs public
ont un devoir absolu devant cette
situation ne pas jeter de l'huile sur le
feu mais au contraire mettre en place
des dispositifs d'apaisement des
décisions structurelles qui permettent
d'avancer vers l'intégration le maintien
de la sécurité et de la cohésion sociale
ces récents événements nous montre qu'il
y a urgence voilà pourquoi ce projet de
résolution émet le souhait que le
gouvernement demande la levée maintenant
des mesures transitoires sans attendre
début 2014 et il en a le pouvoir la
démarche est simple il n'y a pas besoin
d'une nouvelle loi en conclusion cette
résolution répond au souci d'un bon
nombre de collègues élus dans les
municipalités et les communautés
d'agglomér tion de toute couleur
politique nous sommes allés à Bordeaux
nous sommes allés dans la région
nantaise dans le nordp decalais à
Strasbourg en Alsace nous sommes allés
dans tous les départements
d'île-de-fance ces élus aujourd'hui ses
collègues qui se sont engagé qui ont
engagé leur collectivité dans des
démarches et dans la création de lieux
d'accueil de médiation d'insertion qui
ont essayé d'avancer sur les questions
de logement de santé d'accès à la
scolarité sont bloqués parce que y
compris les personnes qui sont dans des
dispositifs ont d'énormes problèmes à à
avoir accès au travail pour les raisons
que je vous ai dites et donc on a là le
risque la fragilisation de dispositifs
et nous ont clairement alerté lors des
auditions des dispositifs qui ont
pourtant été financés par de l'argent
public et souvent avec au départ le
soutien du gouvernement qui sont
fragilisés et mis en danger parce qu'ils
sont interpellés sur le fait qu'on
naboutit pas cette résolution en appelle
donc chers collègues à l'apaisement sur
un sujet dont l'importance a été avant
mai 2012 artificiellement gonflé par
populisme ou par électoralisme je vous
rappelle qu'elle concerne au maximum
20000 personnes en France sur toute la
France en comptant les enfants et les
personnes âgées cette résolution en
appelle à en finir avec les préjugés et
les discriminations et l' en appelle à
établir une égalité de droit entre les
citoyens européens qui sont sur notre
territoire elle en appelle à mettre en
place en France un accueil digne des
traditions de notre République je
terminerai en citant
vaclaavavel citation la façon dont sont
traités les tiganes représentent le vrai
test non seulement pour une démocratie
mais d'abord pour une société
civile réussissons ce test ensemble au
nom de l'apaisement au nom de l'égalité
des droits chers collègues j'ai
confiance en vous et je vous remercie de
votre
attention merci
madamech mes chers collègues la
Conférence des Présidents a décidé que
les interventions des orateurs valaient
explication de vote donc dans la suite
du débat la parole est à Monsieur pierre
Hérisson pour le groupe
UMP
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues madame la
sénatrice
archambou l'inscription à l'ordre du
jour de la proposition de résolution
relative aux ressortissants de
nationalités roumaines et Bulgar
présenté en application de l'article 341
de la Constitution me permet de
m'exprimer à cette tribune aujourd'hui à
double titre tout d'abord en tant
qu'orateur au nom du groupe UMP avec mon
collègue Pierre Charon et ensuite comme
expert représentant pour la France
depuis 2011 au sein du cas Rome donc la
commission de Rome au sein du Conseil de
l'Europe le caroM est le comité adhoc
d'experts sur les questions Romes du
Conseil de l'Europe dont on ne parle que
trop peu malheureusement au niveau
national ce comité se réunit plusieurs
fois par
à Strasbourg et plus récemment à
Istanbul et en Macédoine si les
problématiques relatives à ces
populations doivent être abordé sous le
prisme de la dignité humaine il importe
avant tout pour nous de répondre à une
question précise qui touche au véritable
fond du problème qu est l'avenir pour
ces personnes sur le territoire européen
dans les conditions actuelles cela ne
peut se faire qu'à une seule condition
être à la hauteur du mandat qui est le
nôtre ce qui implique
dépassionner le débat l'appréhender loin
de la démagogie ambiante préciser avec
la plus grande rigueur le cadre des
problématiques qu'il recouvre il
convient dans un premier temps de
préciser les termes les populations de
nationalité Bulgar et roumaines dont
vous faites état dans votre proposition
de résolution madame sont communément
appelés Rome dans leurs pays respectifs
ils appartiennent à une minorité
ethnique d'origine et ils sont constitu
inellement reconnu comme tel ce qui
n'est pas le cas en France notre
République est une et indivisible ne
reconnaît dans sa ne reconnaît pas dans
sa constitution l'existence de minorités
ethniqu en France ces populations sont
bien souvent considérés comme des gens
du voyage amalgam qu'il faut absolument
éviter ce d'autant que les gens du
voyage sont de nationalité française et
ont un véritable statut pour lequel j'ai
d'ailleurs déposé il y a peu de temps
une proposition de loi en vue de
l'amélioration du statut en direction du
droit commun parce qu'ils sont
précisément certes des ressortissant de
l'Union européenne mais aussi des
citoyens de la République
française après cette précision
indispensable je tiens à attirer votre
attention sur un constat simple les
Romes passent quotidiennement nos
frontières et s'installent là où ils le
peuvent pas toujours là où ils le
souhaitent ils y vivent dans des
campements de fortune faute d'autres
solution il n'en demeure pas moins qu'il
s'agit d'un péril humanitaire et social
sur ce point nous sommes tous d'accord
alors arrêtons de céder aux sirènes de
la bienpensance ambiante distinant
l'idée que d'un côté il y aurait les
vilains persécuteurs de Rome et de
l'autre des bienpensants ce sujet
complexe qui mériterait d'ailleurs
qu'une seule heure de plus d'une seule
heure de débat nécessite surtout de la
part des élus qu'ils appréhendent la
réalité sans parti prix aucun des élus
des collectivités que nous sommes et que
nous représentons ne peut nier que l'un
des premiers problèmes tient au fait que
ces campements sont illégaux ce
contrairement à ceux des gens du voyage
pour qui les collectivités s'organisent
aménagent des aires de stationnement
répondre à une législation existante
contraignante mais respectter même s'il
nous reste encore beaucoup de choses à
faire sur ce point votre résolution
madame archambau si elle a le mérite que
nous puissions débattre de ce sujet à la
haute assemblée laisse à croire que les
discriminations en France envers les
Romes seraient d'ordre ethnique je ne
peux pas souscrire à cette définition de
même vous n'abordez ce problème que sous
le prisme de l'expulsion et de la
reconduite à la frontière or le problème
est d'une double nature la circulation
de ces personnes et l'illégalité de
leurs installations ce alors même que
ces personnes peuvent circuler librement
dans l'espace européen vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure aussi sur ce
point vous qui avez tant critiqué la
politique de l'ancienne majorité y
compris tout à l'heure je tiens à faire
observer que depuis le 6 mai dernier les
expulsions des terrains les reconduites
à la frontière n'ont pas cessé ce qui
démontre sans polémique bien ce qui
démontre bien la difficulté à régler ce
problème cet été ce sont plus de 1500
Romes qui ont été évacués à travers la
France dans 550 au moins en moins de 2
mois dans l'agglomération lyonnaise même
s'il faut souligner que 95 personnes ont
été régularisées sur place à
l'initiative du préfet de région le 9
août deux charter décollé de l'aéroport
de saint-exupéri en direction de
Bucharest avec à leur bord pas moins de
personnes dans votre proposition de
résolution vous demandez la levée
anticipée des mesures transitoires qui
limitent l'accès au marché de l'emploi
et de ses ressortissants roumains et
bulgares c'est bien de cela dont il
s'agit laissez-moi vous répondre et et
ce avec tout le respect que je vous dois
est-ce bien réaliste je pose la question
vraiment est-ce bien réaliste la libre
circulation des biens et des personnes
mais aussi des travailleurs s'inscrit
comme l'un des principes fondamentaux de
l'Union européenne mais la France tout
comme neu autres États appliqueent des
restrictions à l'égard des travailleurs
de Roumanie et de Bulgarie cette
dérogation temporaire prendra fin le 1er
janvier de 2014 c'est-à-dire dans un peu
plus de 15 mois pourtant la période
transitoire n'est pas un caprice elle
est nécessaire la sous-estimer comme
période propice à la réflexion
risquerait d'aggraver la situation au
lieu de la résoudre en demandant la
levée de cette période transitoire vous
revenez sur un mécanisme européen adopté
et appliqués par nos partenaires
européens et sur ce point il ne s'agit
pas de Rome de Bulgarie ou de Roumanie
mais d'un mécanisme applicable à de
futurs ressortissants européens qui
pourront d'ailleurs s'inscrire sur les
listes électorales pour les élections
locales dès 2014 c'est pourtant un sujet
sur lequel votre majorité est très
active tout autant qu'elle participe à
créer des amalgames au détriment des
ressortissants étrangers en situation
régulière enfin je voudrais attirer
votre attention sur une autre réalité
celle de la mendicité organisée des vols
à la tire de la délinquence ce n'est pas
autre chose que l'exploitation de la
misère humaine par d'autres sur notre
territoire national aujourd'hui
appréhender les Romes implique de
s'attaquer au réseau qui les exploitent
aujourd'hui c'est et qui s'étendent
parfois jusqu'à la prostitution le
paradoxe pour les services de l'État
français c'est que ces populations sont
à la fois des victimes et des acteurs de
ces fameux réseaux alors ne faudrait-il
pas mettre cette période transitoire à
profit pour trouver des solutions
d'adaptation à une situation totalement
schizophrénique
vous préconisez des solutions
alternatives qui de toute évidence ne
sont pas prêtes ou alors dans une autre
dimension les milieux associatifs le
constatent chaque jour et contrairement
aux promesses d'un candidat à la
présidence de la République les vagues
d'expulsion n'ont pas été suivies de
relogement les familles dont elle
n'était pas quand elle n'étit pas
reconduite à la frontière ont continuer
d'irer dans les rues de dormir dans les
jardins publics ou dans les friches
industrielles pourquoi parce que ce
n'est pas réalisable dans un tel délai
nous n'en avons pas les moyens quel que
soit la majorité en place dans notre
pays c'est pourquoi cette période
transitoire est obligatoire impérative
et au regard de la complexité de la
situation à laquelle nous avons à faire
face nous sommes en droit de nous
demander si elle est même assez longue
ce d'autant plus que nous subissons les
effets d'une très grave crise économique
nous n'avons pas les moyens d'une
politique de générosité et d'intégration
massive beaucoup de gens souffrent en
France dans différents secteurs de notre
société il n'y a pas de hiérarchie dans
la misère il n'est pas scandaleux de
vouloir traiter et répondre à des
questions sociales et économiques
nationales préexistantes à l'intégration
de la Roumanie et de la Bulgarie dans
l'Union européenne je pense à la
situation des gens du voyage qui sont
des citoyens français je vous parle de
400000 personnes sur un sujet ou sur
tous les bans ici je pense que vous
m'accorderez 10 ans de travail et de
travail important pour faire évoluer et
mettre en application la loi baisson sur
lequel je souhaite que nous puissions
prochainement voter un texte de mise à
jour et d'évolution de la loi Baon de
2000 qui a été la pierre fondatrice de
ce que nous avons fait pour les
personnes qui ont décider de vivre en
itinérance dans notre pays ne mettons
pas la charue avant les bœufs aussi je
vous renvoie aux derniers travaux du
caroM qui reflète et participe à
l'élaboration de la position européenne
sur ce le sujet à savoir voir la
budgétisation d'une véritable politique
de développement et d'inclusion de ces
populations dans leur pays d'origine
chaque fois que cela est possible
développer le programme européen destiné
à favoriser l'inclusion de ces
populations en Roumanie et en Bulgarie
doit être notre priorité absolue la
Roumanie et la Bulgarie doivent
respecter leurs engagements et assumer
leurs responsabilités ces pays doivent
mettre en place ces véritables programme
pour lequel aujourd'hui pour le moins on
peut démontrer de grandes lacunes
lorsque je me suis entretenu avec
l'ancien ministre de l'Intérieur roumain
et avec le secrétaire d'État chargé à la
réintégration des Romes de
Roumanie à Bucharest j'ai compris une
chose si ces deux ministres sont
attachés au respect des décisions
européennes conditionnant leur future
intégration à l'Union européenne ils ne
m'ont jamais répondu quant à
l'utilisation des crédits européens
dédiés à l'amélioration des conditions
de leurs minorités cela est proprement
inadmissible aussi malgré les bonnes
intentions de votre texte adopté votre
proposition de résolution serait
véritablement contre-productif le signal
envoyé aux États bulgares et rain au
roumain n'est autre en dépit de millions
d'euros que vous percevez grâce au
contribuables européens ne faites rien
pour gérer vos minorités car la France
s'occupe de tout et endosse la
responsabilité à votre place adopte
votre
résolution reviendrai à déc is l'Europe
puisque vous renillez les mécanismes mis
en place par nos partenaires européens
qu'il nous faut respecter adopter votre
proposition de résolution c'est avoir la
prétention de croire qu'une initiative
nationale française peut se substituer
au travail mené avec nos partenair en
faveur de ces populations alors que
l'Espagne vient de réduire les
possibilités d'accès au travail la crise
est une évidence là-bas aussi et
peut-être plus que chez nous c'est
désacralisé la nécessité la nécessaire
le pardon le nécessaire respect des
engagements auxquels doivent se
conforter les états candidats et en
phase d'intégration c'est tout
simplement décrédibiliser le processus
d'adhésion et d'intégration à l'Union
européenne dans ses principes et le
respect des engagements enfin c'est
laisser croire aux associations et à ces
populations que nous sommes en capacité
de les accueillir dignement et que nous
pouvons dispenser de nous dispenser de
solutions qui ne peuvent être
qu'européennes et transitoires
alors madame arch aussi louable que soi
vos intentions et je vous l'accorde vous
comprendrez que le groupe de l'UMF
votera contre cette
proposition merci mon cher collègue dans
la suite de la discussion la parole est
à Monsieur jean-ve lecte pour le groupe
socialiste monsieur le Président
Monsieur le
Ministre madame la sénatrice archambau
mes chers collègues la semaine dernière
l'Union européenne s'est vu attribuer le
Prix Nobel de la paix ainsi l'une des
plus formidables constructions
politiques de l'après- guerre ét
récompensé pour avoir institué en Europe
un espace de paix et de sécurité
définissant une citoyenneté européenne
garantissant des droits fondamentaux
comme la liberté de circulation et
d'installation force de constater que
cette construction fragile complexe ne
va pas de soi qu'elle provoque lors de
chaque phase d'intégration des moments
de crainte et de doute ces moments sont
encore plus difficiles voire risqué
lorsque la situation économique et
sociale est douloureuse engendrant
d'inévitables tensions il était
toutefois historiquement symbolique et
politiquement nécessaire de ne pas
laisser de côté une partie significative
de l'autre Europe après le grand
élargissement de
2004 cette conviction a dominé
l'ensemble des négociations d'entrée
dans l'Union européenne de la Roumanie
et de la Bulgarie mais intégrer ces
états qui disposent d'un PIB de l'ordre
de 25 % de la moyenne des PIBS des États
de l'Union européenne représentait un
enjeu administratif et économique très
important lorsqu'on regarde aujourd'hui
les situations politiques en Hongrie et
Roumanie d'une part en Ukraine de
l'autre on mesure combien ce
volontarisme politique était
indispensable pour éviter tout retour en
arrière sur le plan démocratique comme
en 2004 et les vagues migratoires venu
de Pologne et des pays bal surtout vers
l'Irlande et le Royaume-Uni la libre
circulation a vite engendré une
inquiétude les Roumains et les Bulgares
n'allaiit-il pas déferler sur le marché
de marché de l'emploi déjà très tendu et
engendrer un appel à la baisse des
salaires c'est face à cette crainte que
des états-memes ont souhaité mettre en
place des mesures transitoires de
protection de leur marché du travail
c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui pour la
France mais aussi pour l'Allemagne ou
l'Espagne pourtant un rapport de la
commission sur le fonctionnement des r
dispositions transitoires sur sur la
libre circulation des travailleurs en
provenance de la Bulgarie et de la
Roumanie en date de novembre 2011 a
salué l'impact de ces a évaluer l'impact
de ces mesures transitoires tant pour la
Bulgarie et la Roumanie que pour les
pays de migration c'est à cette date que
la seule étude d'impact de référence sur
la question a été publié et que dis ce
rapport indépendamment de leur
participation au marché du travail on
estime à à peu près 2,9 millions de
personnes le nombre de ressortissants
bulgares et roumains installés dans l'un
des 25 autres pays de l'Union européenne
et cette mobilité est souvent antérieure
à la date d'adhésion de ces pays à
l'Union européenne l'Italie l'Espagne et
l'Allemagne hébergent plus de 75 % de
l'ensemble des travailleurs bulgares et
roumains les flux de mobilité suivent
bien évidemment les périodes de
croissance économique ainsi l'arrivée de
travailleurs Bulgar et roumains s'est
fortement ralenti depuis 2009 et quand
l'Espagne a réintroduit le 22 juillet
2011 des restrictions déjà plus de 50 %
des travailleurs migrants en provenance
de ces deux États avaient déjà quitté
l'Espagne car ils étaient priv
d'emploi les les profils professionnels
des travailleurs migrants sont rarement
qualifiés et les métiers concernés
directement liés à la conjoncture
économique construction servicees
domestiques hôtellerie restauration
pourtant comme le montrre en France des
études réalité par Pôle Emploi plusieurs
de ces métiers font aujourd'hui l'objet
de nombreuses offres d'emploi non
pourvu surtout ce rapport de la
commission au-delà de la simple analyse
statistique tire des conclusions
importantes pour l'analyse de la
résolution qui nous est soumise
aujourd'hui d'une part je cite il est
clair que les citoyens mobiles récemment
arrivés en provenance de Bulgarie et de
Roumanie ont joué un rôle très mineur
dans la crise du marché du travail des
différents pays par exemple en 2010 il
représentait seulement 1 % de l'ensemble
des personnes au chômage dans les pays
de l'Union 15 à des 15 premiers pays de
l'union des 15 anciens pays de l'Union
européenne contera 4,1 % pour des
ressortissants des paystiers récemment
arrivés d'autre part la la vaste
majorité des citoyens mobiles récemment
arrivés de Bulgarie et Roumanie
participe au marché du travail dans la
même mesure que la que leur population
que la population moyenne voire de
manière plus importante dans l'ensemble
ils ont joué un rôle positif pour les
économies des pays d'accueil ce sont ces
conclusions de la commission qui on
incité le Parlement européen à adopté le
15 décembre 2011 une résolution sur la
libre circulation des travailleurs à
l'intérieur de l'Union européenne
résolution votée aussi bien par le PPE
le PSE les libéraux que les vers
européens tout comme une résolution sur
les mesures d'encourage de à la mobilité
des travailleurs à l'intérieur de
l'Union européenne le 25 octobre 2011 il
faut souhaiter chers collègues que notre
attachement à la construction européenne
nous conduisent aujourd'hui à faire un
choix similaire aujourd'hui ma collègue
Aline archambau nous propose de voter
une résolution relative aux
ressortissants de nationalités roumaines
et Bulgar beaucoup ont voulu y voir une
résolution essentiellement destinée à
favoriser l'insertion en France des
migrants Rome et c'est en partie
vrai à ce stade plusieurs remarques
marque mérite toutefois d'être faite la
proportion de migrants d'origine Rome
est conforme à leur proportion
démographique dans leur état d'origine
plus ou moins 10 %. grâce à la liberté
de prestation de servicees dans l'Union
européenne il est aujourd'hui possible
déjà de travailler en France en toute
légalité quand on vient de Bulgarie ou
de Roumanie dans ce cas les cotisations
sociales des employés détachés en France
ne sont pas payés en France mais dans le
pays d'origine de l'entreprise ainsi la
CGT ne faisait-elle pas remarquer
l'année dernière que B construction
employé sur le chantier de l'opre de
flamandville un tiers d'ouvriers
roumains par le biais d'entreprise
sous-traitante roumaine notons
simplement que cette main d'œuvre a
l'avantage d'être payé 9 € de l'heure et
de ne pas être syndqué et les
cotisations sociales sont payées en
Roumanie nous pourrions parler du même
type de montage chez certaines des
entreprises de transport qui emploient
des chauffeurs routiers bulgares sur des
cycles de 14 jours donner d'autres
possibilités de travailler légalement en
France participera au relèvement des
droits sociaux des migrants européens et
de leur salaire comme cela a été le cas
pour les états intégrer l'Union
européenne en 2004 il existe en France
des filières d'emploi qui fonctionnent
de façon clandestine car à côté des 15 à
20000 Romes qui vivent dans des
conditions indignes ce sont plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de Bulgares et de
Roumains qui occupent des emplois dans
le BTP l'hôtellerie ou la restauration
ce sont ces travailleurs qui font la
fortune de marchand de sommeil ainsi
cette résolution en demandant la
suppression des mesures transitoires
permet de proposer une alternative au
détachement de personnel où aucune
cotisation sociale n'est payée en France
et elle liquide toute possibl
explication à ceux qui emploient de
manière illégale de la main d'œuvre
bulgare ou roumaine en France en
exploitant leur précarité et leur
illégalité il convient aussi de rappeler
que la Roumanie et la Bulgarie ont
respecté dans leur processus d'adhésion
l'esprit des traités européens sur la
liberté de circulation et d'installation
en imposant aucune réciprocité aux
mesures transitoires demandées par la
France comme l'avait fait par exemple la
Pologne en 2004 en effet Varsovie
considérant que ces mesures comme
discriminatoires vis-à-vis de ses
concitoyens et contraire à l'esprit des
traités décida d'appliquer une récip
procité des barrières à l'embourche pour
les ressortissants des États pratiquant
ces typ d'enclave ceci a été levé en
même temps que nous levions les mesures
transitoires pour les ressortissants
polonais il y a quelques années et ceci
sans aucun effet négatif pour l'emploi
qu'urait dit d'ailleurs la France si
Renault avait dû affronter ce type de
situation avec l'administration roumaine
dans la gestion de ses expatriés
travaillant sur le site d'cha de
pitch que demande formellement la
relation la résolution qui nous est
présentée elle s'inscrit dans la volonté
de la nouvelle la majorité de marquer
une rupture avec la politique de
stigmatisation et de refus d'intégration
des migrants dont le discours de
Grenoble a constitué le néfaste point
d'org ceci fut à la fois une
justification une théorisation du refus
des valeurs républicaines toutefois
déposée en juillet cette résolution a
perdu une part de son actualité grâce à
l'action du gouvernement la circulaire
interministérielle du 26 août 2012
marque la volonté du gouvernement mené
par Jean-Marc HUD d'avoir une vision
intégrée des enjeux liés à l'apparition
et au démantelllement des lieux de vie
indigne ainsi qu'à l'insertion des
populations les habitants elle soulligne
que l'intégration se fait par le travail
et par l'école comme le demande la
proposition discutée aujourd'hui mais
déposé en juillet 2012 cette circulaire
supprime la perception de la taxe offi
pour toute délivrance de titre de séjour
ouvre l'accès des ressortissants
bulgares et roumains au service de Pôle
emploi et leur permet d'intégrer des
filières de formation professionnelle ce
texte cette circulaire fondatrice est
accompagné de trois circulaires visant à
garantir la scolarisation de tous les
enfants de 6 à 16 ans quel que soit leur
niveau et leurs origines et depuis la
semaine dernière un arrêté a élargi de
façon significative la liste des emplois
accessibles aux Bulgares et aux Roumains
cet arsenal de texte est accompagné par
la nomination d'un délégué
interministériel le préfet Alain RET en
charge de la
dial dont la principale fonction est
l'appui méthodologique et la
coordination des différentes
administrations en charge de ce qui sera
la nouvelle stratégie d'inclusion des
Romes l'objectif est bien entrer dans le
droit commun de toutes ces populations
des difficultés malgré tout demeure
d'une part il est urgent de compter sur
la mobilisation pleine et entière de nos
administrations préfectur et
collectivités locales pour coordonner
l'action sur le terrain des acteurs
impliqués dans les radications des
bidonvillees et l'insertion sociale de
leurs habitants ainsi est-il normal que
la procédure administrative conduisant à
la délivrance d'un titre de séjour
prenne de 6 à 8 mois que l'on soit ou
vulgare ou non d'ailleurs que des mur
refusent l'inscription d'enfants à
l'école ou des domiciliations permettant
notamment l'accès aux soins et les
préfectures appliquent-elles toute la
circulaire du 26 août et d'ailleurs on
ent-elle vraiment les moyens est-il
normal que de plus en plus les pouvoirs
publics se dérobent dans leur mission de
lutte contre la grande pauvreté et
d'intégration sociale en fermant des
lieux de vie indignne sans s'occuper du
S de ceux qui les occupent pourtant les
difficultés d'accès au logement est une
réalité qui qui touche des Fran de plus
en plus importante de notre population
l'effort demandé à notre communauté
nationale à l'égard de ces habitants les
plus fragilisés ne saurait être porté de
plus en plus par les collectivités
locales les migration l'intégration
étant des enjeux rencontrés par la
plupart des pays de l'Union européenne
il serait légitime de renégocier
partiellement la stratégie nationale
d'inclusion et d'initier sur la
programmation des fonds structurels pour
la période 2014 2020 une politique
nouvelle à destination des collectivités
pour soutenir leur politique de soutien
à
l'intégration plus rapidement les Fonds
structurels à destination de la Roumanie
et qui sont aujourd'hui inutilisé ne
pourrait-il pas être réaffecté aux
collectivités locales françaises qui
développent des programmes d'intégration
avec un peu plus de moyens il serait
plus facile de travailler sur un
ensemble de politiques qui permettrai un
changement de regard de la population
pour que les stéréotypes et le racisme
ambiant ne deviennent pas une barrière
de plus en plus visible freinant la
nécessaire intégration la nécessaire
insertion des personnes qui le
souhaitent pour conclure le vote de
cette résolution est nécessaire même si
de nombreuses propositions qu'elle porte
sont déjà caduques surtout un autre
débat est à initier celui du contrôle
des mendalités de mise en œuvre des
différents textes rédigés par le
gouvernement depuis la fin août 2012
ceci pourrait être par exemple le rôle
d'un groupe de travail sénatorial danst
la voocation serait déévaluer la mise en
œuvre des différents textes émis par le
gouvernement depuis la fin août ainsi
que la stratégie nationale d'insertion
que le gouvernement s'est engagé à
réviser rappelons ici la promesse de
François Hollande lors de la campagne
présidentielle et c'est ces ces ces
paroles envers Rome europeope les
Roumains et les Bulgares quelle que
soient leurs origines sont des citoyens
européens les mesures transitoires qui
limitent encore leurs droits feront
l'objet d'un examen objectif en en
accord avec la résolution du Parlement
européen du 25 octobre 2011 et du
rapport de la Commission européenne du
11 novembre 2011 grâce à la circulaire
du 26 août dernier ce que demande cette
résolution C ces engagements sont déjà
partiellement réalisés et le reste
semble aujourd'hui àortter demain c'est
la raison pour laquelle constatant le
chemin parcouru sur la question depuis
le 6 mai le groupe socialiste votera
cette
résolution merci Monsieur le Comte la
parole est à Monsieur Michel Billou pour
le groupe
CRC monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues je ne me prétends pas être un
expert du sujet juste un parlementaire
qui proposera dans un mois un rapport à
la commission des affaires européennes
concernant les populations Romes au sein
de l'Union européenne après 6 mois de
travail cette proposition de résolution
présenté par nos collègues du groupe
écologiste relative au ressortissants
roumains et bulgares présents en France
ouvre au Sénat un débat nécessaire au
moment où l'État et les collectivités
locales sont confrontés à des situations
parfois délicates et souvent mal géré
même si cette proposition de résolution
ne concerne pas que les populations
Romes les dispositions visées les
frappent princiement principalement une
vingtaine de milliers d'hommes de femmes
et d'enfants de nationalité roumaine
majoritairement mais également Bulgar ou
en provenance de nombreux pays des
Balcans ayant la particularité d'être
Rome au sens défini par les institutions
européennes réside actuellement en
France et contrairement à une idée reçue
ce nombre est resté stable depuis
plusieurs années ce nombre est très
faible au regard de la population de
notre pays mais la dimension
politico-médiatique du sujet est parfois
considérable cela tient au fait qu'il
s'agit d'une population fortement
discriminée en Europe depuis de nombreux
siècles et dont l'arrivée en France est
très mal supporté ils sont confondus
avec les gens du voyage français ce qui
est une erreur ou perçu comme des
étrangers migrants ce qui est une autre
forme d'erreur en tous les cas pour ce
qui les concerne c'est la double peine
il constitue donc un problème et avec
toutes les guillemets que je peux y
mettre le constat est connu il s'agit
d'une immigration économique la
situation des populations Rome s'est en
effet terriblement dégradée dans les
pays d'Europe centrale et des Balcans
depuis les années
1990 avec l'abandon ou la privatisation
de P entier de l'industrie à alors que
le plein d'emploi était pratiquement
assuré aux hommes et en partie aux
femmes le taux de chômage concernant les
populations Romes avoisine aujourd'hui
les 90 % dans ces pays immigré en France
la situation dramatique de ces personnes
provient de l'absence de revenus légaux
qui entraînent une extrême précarité et
des conditions de vie indignes le plus
souvent dans des compements de fortune
insalubre à cela s'ajoute une forte
hostilité à leur égard leur situation
d'extrême pauvreté en fait également des
proies faciles pour les réseaux
criminels et je tiens à assurer ici
qu'ils sont plus souvent victime
cuteur les auteurs de la proposition de
résolution considèrent que déjà
stigmatisé en France et en Europe bien
que citoyens européens les Roumains et
les Bulgares sont victimes d'une
discrimination supplémentaire de la part
de l'État français en raison de
l'application de dispositions freinant
considérablement leur accès à un emploi
légal la France applique en effet au
ressortissants bulgares et roumains le
statut transitoire négocié avec ces deux
pays lors de leur adhésion à l'Union
européenne ce statut a en particulier
pour conséquence que les Roumains et les
Bulgares peuvent comme tous les citoyens
européens se déplacer librement dans
l'Union européenne donc venir en France
mais sans avoir pleinement le droit d'y
travailler citoyens européens de seconde
zone ils ne peuvent donc être embauchés
qu'en fonction d'une liste restreinte de
métier à condition que l'employeur paye
une taxe supplémentaire et à la suite
d'un long dél instruction de leur
dossier administratif trop souvent 9
mois reconnaissons que si ces fameuses
mesures transitoires s'appliquent en
principe à tous les travailleurs
roumains et bulgares elle touche bien
plus fortement les populations déjà
fragilisées plutôt que les médecins
roumains par exemple accueillis plus
chaleureusement sur notreosol sans
parler des entreprises roumaines
sous-traitantes très prisées du patronat
du patronat français ce statut
dérogatoire au droits commun européens
et quand on y réfléchit bien assez
choquant et conduit mécaniquement à des
situations inextricables cet été
l'évacuation et le démantellement par
les forces de police de campement de
famille Rome occupant illégalement des
terrain a légitimement choqué une grande
partie de l'opinion publique et suscité
la réprobation des associations qui
œuvrent auprès de ses familles et que je
tiens à saluer ici il est vrai que la
différence de méthode avec la politique
menée en ce domaine par le précédent
gouvernement a pu ne pas apparaître très
clairement l'évacuation de ces
campements est évidemment toujours une
réponse brutale à des situations
humaines et sociales complexe il a ainsi
souvent été reproché au gouvernement de
faire précéder le démantèlement sur la
recherche de solution préalable et même
parfois comme à éry de procéder à
l'évacuation avant une décision de
justice la réunion interministérielle du
22 août qui a abouti à la définition due
nouvelle politique à l'égard des
populations Rome a malheureusement été
davantage perçu comme une tentative de
faire oublier la vague de démantellement
de camp qui l'avait précédé la décision
du gouvernement d'assouplir les
conditions d'embauche en élargissant la
liste des métier ouvert au roumains et
au bulgares et en supprimant la taxe du
par les employeurs est un bon signe mais
elle risque cependant d'être peu d' fait
car les dispositifs qu'ell nécessit ne
pourront vraisemblablement pas être mis
en place avant la levée de ces mesures
de toute façon prévu dans 15 mois
elle a toutefois le mérite de mettre en
évidence une liste de près de 300
métiers en France qui ne trouvent pas
suffisamment preneur et dont notre
société a besoin c'est pourquoi j'estime
que la proposition de résolution de
demandant en premier lieu au
gouvernement de lever immédiatement et
intégralement les mesures transitoires
concernant l'accès à l'emploi est
pleinement justifié les mesures
transitoires n'ont servi à rien aucune
véritable étude d'impact n'a été
réalisée pendant ces 5 années à demi
elles seront levées dans 15 mois cela ne
sert à rien d'attendre bien au contraire
il s'agit d'un élément important qu'il
conviendra de compléter afin de résoudre
l'ensemble des difficultés rencontrées
par ces populations c'est l' intégration
de ceux qui sont venus en France et non
leur exclusion leur expulsion qui
permettra vraiment de trouver une
solution durable à ces difficultés
l'accès au travail devra donc être
complété par d'autres mesures
d'accompagnement au plan de la formation
ce que demande également la résolution
mais aussi du logement de l'accès aux
soins et de l'éducation des enfants
c'est un ensemble de dispositifs qui
dorait être pilotés par l'État lequel
s'en remet trop souvent au collectivité
local réduite à gérer une situation
d'accueil à laquelle ne sont pas préparé
et dans un contexte économique où leurs
budgets sont mis à mal je voudrais
ajouter que cette question ne doit pas
faire l'objet dans notre pays d'un
traitement que je qualifierais
d'ethnique il s'agit simplement
d'appliquer le droit commun et de venir
en aide à des citoyens européens des
migrants économiques qui sont victime de
conditions économiques et sociales
déplorables enfin cette question ne
peut-être du seul ressort de chaque État
membre de l'Union européenne ces
situation existe dans de nombreux pays
doivent faire l'objet d'un traitement
d'ensemble plus cohérents l'Union
européenne a décidé de coordonner des
stratégies nationales seulement après la
vague d'expulsion de Rome en France
pendant pendant l'été 2010 et qui avait
mis alors la France à l'index elle se
doit aujourd'hui de rendre plus efficace
son intervention auprès de l'ensemble
des États concernés qu'il soit qualifié
d'accueil ou d'origine il faudrait
notamment que l'Union européenne rende
plus opérationnelle l'utilisation des
fonds structurels destiné à la lutte
contre la pauvreté à l'insertion par
l'emploi à la scolarisation notamment et
qu'elle impulse mieux la lutte contre
l'antiziganisme véritable le fond de
commerce des organisations politiques
d'extrême droite en Europe comme en
France en conclusion la proposition de
résolution de nos collègues du groupe
écologiste permettrait si était adopté
d'engager une dynamique positive contre
les discriminations c'est pourquoi le
groupe communiste républicain et
citoyens votera en sa
faveur merci mon cher collègue la parole
est à Monsieur Vincent de la pour le
groupe
UCR
voir c'est
Monsieur bien ça
va monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues pour bien comprendre le sujet
que nous examinons aujourd'hui il est
utile de rappeler le processus qui a
conduit à l'adhésion de la Roumanie et
la Bulgarie à l'Union européenne le 1er
janvier
2007 cette adhésion s'inscrit dans le
prolongement du grand élargissement
européen de de 2004 qui a entériné
l'adhésion de pays d'Europe centrale et
de
l'Est l'ensemble de ce processus au
cours des années 2000 participe d'une
logique d'élargissement qui à mon sens
n'a pas été suffisamment précédé de
l'approfondissement nécessaire des
relations entre les États fondateurs de
l'Union européenne l'élargissement s'est
donc fait dans une certaine mesure au
détriment de l'approfondissement
fragilisant ainsi la construction
européenne
cet élément est bien sûr important dans
le débat qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui car si nous examinons la
question des citoyens roumains et
bulgares aujourd'hui c'est justement
parce qu'ils sont devenus en 2007 des
ressortissants
communautaires et qu'aujourd'hui encore
je m'interroge sur la pertinence et
l'urgence de l'adhésion de pays qui
traitaent une partie de leur population
de façon notoirement
discriminatoire le problème auquel nous
AV à faire face aujourd'hui était donc
largement prévisible et certains d'entre
nous l'avaient malheureusement
anticipé ces difficultés d'intégration
de la communauté Rome en Roumanie
notamment ont favorisé en plus des
difficultés économiques le départ des
Romes de leur pays d'origine vers la
plupart des autres pays communautaires
dont la
France ces départs ont été bien sûr
facilité par l'entrée dans un espace de
libre circulation où les exigences de
visa ont disparu
alors quelle est la situation
aujourd'hui la Roumanie et la Bulgarie
sont membres de l'Union européenne et
conformément à la faculté offerte par
leur acte d'adhésion la France a décidé
d'instaurer à compté du 1er janvier 2007
une période transitoire de 7 ans en
matière de libre circulation des
travailleurs
salariés ce régime dérogatoire prévoit
qu'à l'issue d'un délai de 3 mois passé
sur le sol français roumain et bulgares
doivent avoir un emploi suivre des
études ou justifier de ressources
suffisante et avoir une assurance
maladie pour pouvoir rester en
France le type d'emplois qu'il peuvent
occuper était jusqu'à cet été limité à
150 métiers connaissant des difficultés
de
recrutement à ce sujet la proposition de
résolution suggère d'une part la levée
immédiate des dispositions transitoires
en matière d'accès à l'emploi et d'autre
part que les ressortissants roumains et
bulgares de moins de 26 ans aent accès à
la formation dans les mêmes conditions
que les ressortissants
communautaires sur ces deux aspects nous
serions prêts à vous suivre chers
collègues dans la mesure où il ne
s'agirait que de réduire d'un an la
durée de ces mesures
transitoires mais il en va différemment
des autres propositions de la
résolution en effet vous nous proposez
de nous prononcer au sein d'un même
texte non amendable sur des thématiques
parfaitement différentes quel lien entre
d'une part les conditions d'accès à
l'emploi et d'autre part les conditions
d'expulsion de camp occupés de façon
illicite notons d'ailleurs la subtilité
sémantique de des auteurs de la
proposition de résolution qui parle de
lieu de vie
irrégulier je pense que vous en auriez
vous auriez en fait rencontré un plus
grand succès si vous vous étiez limité à
des problématiques cohérentes entre
elles comme le sont effectivement celles
qui concerne l'accès au travail et
l'accès à la formation en voulant en
faire trop vous perdez cette cohérence
et vous en arrivez à associer des
problématiques qui certes concernent en
l'espèce les mêmes personnes mais qui
sur le fond des mesures n'ont aucun
rapport entre elles
votre dernier souhait relatif aux
expulsions de camp occupés de façon
illégale puisque c'est bien comme cela
qu'il faut les appeler sous-entend
implicitement qu'aujourd'hui l'ensemble
des dispositifs existants relatifs à
l'accompagnement social individualisé au
droit au logement et à l'hébergement ne
sont pas
mobilisés je suis navré mais je ne
partage pas cette interprétation j'ai
moi-même en tant que maire de Massie eu
à plusieurs reprises expérience de ces
situations et je et je dément que tous
les moyens humains et matériel ne soit
pas régulièrement mise en œuvre
aujourd'hui notamment par les
travailleurs sociaux qui font un travail
remarquable cette proposition marquée au
coin du bon sentiment à vouloir élargir
fortement les droits des Romes au met
dans un mal bien français de rappeler
certains
devoirs le devoir des Romes eux-mêmes de
ne pas investir de manière illicite des
terrains communaux ou
autres je félicite à ce sujet la fermeté
du ministre de l'Intérieur qui rappelle
que tout n'est pas possible dans notre
pays et que la loi s'impose à tous à
juste titre donc manuel Val a procédé à
l'expulsion de plusieurs camps illicites
comme l'avait fait son
prédécesseur observons d'ailleurs un
traitement médiatique bien différent que
n'a-t-on entendu dans un cas pour quel
silence
aujourd'hui sans doute cette fermeté lui
vient-elle de l'expérience qu'il a
engrangé en tant que maire
d'evri cela me permet au passage pour
nourrir un débat qui sera bientôt le
nôtre de dire à ceux qui souhaitent
absolument imposer le non cumul d'un
mandat de parlementaire avec un exécutif
local que seule la réalité du terrain
est prouvée comme je la connais comme
Manuel Vals l'a connu peut faire entrer
dans nos raisonnement et décisions le
sens des responsabilités et les motifs
d'ordre public qui s'imposent à
l'ensemble des exécutifs locaux que l'on
soit de gauche de droite ou du
centre mais mes chers collègues
le sens du devoir doit aussi être appelé
au pays d'origine des populations Rome
pays auquel l'Union européenne a versé
des sommes considérables pour aider à
l'intégration de ces communautés pour
quel
résultat je garde en tête les paroles de
Pierre Lelouche alors secrétaire d'État
aux Affaires européennes qui disait en
2010 ce serait une bien curieuse
interprétation de la lettre des traités
que de considérer que certains pays
puissent offrir comme seule perspective
à leurs citoyens Rome celle d'émigrer
vers les pays européens les plus riches
auxquels reviendrait hipsof factao la
charge de les
intégrer nous comptons ajoutait-il sur
la Roumanie et la Bulgarie pour qu'elles
prennent leur responsabilité à l'égard
de leurs propres citoyens car avant la
liberté de circuler d'un pays à l'autre
de l'Union européenne il y a le devoir
pour chaque État membre d'assurer la
protection et l'intégration de ses
propres
ressortissant les discussions entamées
en son temps par Pierre Lelouche avec la
Roumanie et la Bulgarie doivent se
poursuivre si nous voulons avancer sur
cette question pour toutes ces raisons
le groupe Union des démocrates et
indépendants Union centriste ne votera
pas en faveur de cette résolution tant
pour son manque de cohérence que pour
l'accent qu'elle met sur les droits à
augmenter sans jamais insister sur les
devoirs à respecter je vous
remercie merci mon cher collègu la
parole est au président Jacques mard
pour le groupe
RDSE ça veut dire quoi ne pas voter oui
oui monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je connais l'implication
personnelle de notre collègue madame
archambau dans ce dossier sa générosité
personnelle
son souci de l'humain qui sont à la base
de sa démarche cela non seulement mon
groupe le sait mais il le comprend et il
le respecte nous ne nous sommes jamais
inscrits dans le fil des du discours de
Grenoble nous l'avons combattu fermement
mais de grâce aujourd'hui pas de
simplification ative pas
d'anathème tous les Romes ne sont pas
dans des bidonville heureusement et des
milliers d'entre eux s'insère
normalement dans la société
française si nous nous abstiendrons
majoritairement sur ce texte c'est pour
deux raisons
fondamentales la première c'est qu'une
grande partie des orientations de ce
texte déposé je le rappelle le 13 juin
2012 a été satisfait par la circulaire
du gouvernement en date du 26 août 2012
et aussi par l'arrêté du 10 octobre
publié est un hasard hier
soir la seconde et donc nous faisons
confiance bien sûr à la politique qui
est menée par le gouvernement puisque la
seconde
raison découlant logiquement de la
première c'est qu'il nous paraît en
conséquence que la politique qui a été
mise en œuvre ces derniers mois par le
gouvernement et en particulier par le
ministre de l'Intérieur manuel Vals est
conforme à ce que nous souhaitons
avec deux objectifs mis en parallèle
application de la loi de la République
et des décisions de justice traitement
égal et digne de toute personne en
situation de détresse sociale dans ces
conditions quel est aujourd'hui le but
véritable de cette proposition de
résolution certes pas à notre avis de
faciliter l'action du gouvernement dans
un dossier dont on connaî la
difficulté médiatique déplorable au
profit hélas le plus souvent de
l'extrême droite y y a-t-il des
propositions concrète de construction en
matière de logement social de classe
adapté pour la lutte contre l'idltrisme
maises chers collègues ce qui s'est
passé à Marseille le 28 septembre est
grave et devrait faire réfléchir ceux
qui considèrent l'angélisme comme la
solution et une politique d'immigration
sans aucun filtre comme le meilleur
chemin vers un monde
ce qui s'est passé à Marseille le 28
septembre la destruction par les
citoyens voisins d'un camp d'occupation
illicite est intolérable doit être
dénoncé doit être sanctionné mais hélas
cela se reproduira s'il n'est pas mis
fin à ces occupations illicites dans des
conditions qui sont inacceptables pour
les riverins la plupart du temps pour
les occupants eux-mêmes et même toujours
marginalisés au contact d'une
contagieuse constituant la seule école
de vie pour les enfants conditions de
santé déplorable absence d'école de
formation intégration dans la République
quasi impossible cela ne veut pas dire
que l'argent n'y circule pas dans ces
zones de nombrois de nroit je ne ferai
aucune comparaison ne déplairai pas à
notre collègue hérisson et je ne ferai
aucune comparaison avec certains
regroupements de gens du voyage qu'il
connaît où les véhicules haut de gamme
vont de P avec l'absence de revenus
fiscaux c'est tout tout à fait différent
on peut traiter de ce problème avec
beaucoup de certitude d'humanisme de
discours dans les restaurants parisiens
où se retrouve politique et journalistes
donneur de leçons mais quand il faut les
gérer sur le terrain c'est une autre
affaire c'est la notre élus locaux
responsables des collectivités locales
il n'est pas raisonnable d'augmenter le
nombre d'arrivées de Rome sur les
territoires nationaux ni de continuer à
tolérer les occupations illégales de
terrain résoudre les problèmes humains
oui faciliter l'accès à l'emploi oui
chers collègues sur l'accès à l'emploi
l'arrêté qui a été publié hier vise une
liste de
291 métiers ouverts aux ressortissants
c'est-à-dire ça balayille tous les
métiers qui peuvent être l'objet des
demandes de ces ressortissants les Romes
viennent de Roumanie et de Bulgarie deux
pays membres de l'Union depuis 2 et dont
la responsabilité est importante dans la
situation actuelle responsabilité
d'autant plus forte que l'Union
européenne a mis à disposition des
crédits importants pour l'intégration
des Romes dans leur propre pays et que
la Roumanie n'avait pas hésité à émettre
une réserve interprétative sur la
déclaration de Strasbourg du Conseil de
l'Europe du 20 octobre 2010 concernant
la participation active des Romes à leur
insertion sociale la Roumanie aosant
déclarer que la responsabilité
d'intégrer les Romes incombent au pays
d'accueil après 3 mois de séjour c'est
facile de se défausser sur les autres
quand on est souvent à l'origine du
problème si roumains et bulgares ne sont
pas encore membres de l'espace Schengen
c'est en raison de leur retard en
matière de lutte contre la corruption et
le crime organisé ainsi que de
régulation de flux
migratoires l'action menée par le
gouvernement depuis cet été et la
circulaire du 26 août l'arrêté du 1er
octobre correspondent à des mesures de
bon sens alliant le respect de la loi et
de la personne humaine la circulaire met
au préalable l'accent sur la mise en
œuvre de solutions d'accompagnement le
plus en amont des décisions de justice
avec des diagnostics anticipés
individualisés dans les domaines de la
scolarisation de la santé de l'emploi et
de l'hébergement et dans le délai
séparant l'installation et l'évacuation
une évaluation en coopération entre tous
les acteurs cette circulaire prévoit la
garantie de la continuité de l'accès aux
droits des personnes principe
d'obligation scolaire accès aux soins à
la mobilisation de façon individualisé
des solutions d'hébergement d'urgence en
favorisant aussi les parcours
d'insertion avec pédagogie et aussi
parce que ça a été décidé par le
gouvernement la suppression de la taxe
du c'est fait le gouvernement s'est
engagé à allonger la liste des métiers
accessibles ça vient d'être fait a
étudieré la levée des mesures
transitoires de restriction d'accès à
l'emploi dans ce dossier nous
considérons monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues que le gouvernement a
fait du bon travail le ministre de
l'Intérieur a montré très clairement que
fermeté dans l'application de la loi de
la République allit de paire avec
respect des personnes et des droits
fondamentaux la résolution de nos
collègues écologiste et en particulier
la fin de la résolution qui bloquerait
de fait toute possibilité d'expulsion
d'installation illégale procède d'une
vision un peu différente de la nôtre de
la République au-delà des soucis
humanitaires humanitaire c'est pourquoi
la majorité de notre groupe
s'abstiendra merci Monsieur mard la
parole est à Madame ester Benbassa pour
le groupe
écologie bonjour
madame monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues je vous pose une question
pourquoi les Romes nous font-ils si peur
cette peur a une histoire permettez-moi
de vous en rappeler l'essentiel en
quelques phrase au 17e siècle le destin
de la nation bohémienne bascule la
montée de l'intolérance accompagne de la
promulgation de règlements et de
l'instauration de sanctions d'une
sévérité qui se généralise privé de
l'accueil des châteaux où les
Égyptiennes et leur spectacles de danse
suscit un véritable engouement exclu des
compagnies de gendarmes chassé des
villes assimilé à des errants et
vagabonds et pour chasser à ce titre
dans toute l'Europe interdit de contact
dans l'impossibilité d'exercer une
activité itinérante mais légal les
tiganes vont voir leur situation se
dégrader au 18e siècle l'opinion
administrative englobe désormais les
bohémiens dans la catégorie des Vaga
Gabon mendiant et gens sans aveu il y a
un siècle presque exactement le 4 mars
1907 un long article du matin consacré
au bohémiens et romanichel énumérait
encore sans honte les mots nombreux
impliqués par le nomadisme des ciganes
ce péril errant je cite pillard
propagateur d'épidémie meurtrier
empoisonneur insaisissable hors la loi
ainsi sont-ils présentés redoutés comme
des espions en période de guerre comme
des voleurs le reste du temps voleurs de
poule ou d'enfants quant aux femmes
tiganes on leur reproche leur lubricité
et honté vous n'aurez pas oubli chers
collègues la carmene de bisé inspirée de
mrimet au cours de l'histoire les États
européens se sont efforcés de réprimer
la mobilité cigane perçue comme une
déviance sociale
d'imposer la
sédentarisation aux familles nomades
sans pour autant au fond les tolérer
davantage ce qui fait peur c'est leur
nomadisme aujourd'hui les Romes venus
des Balcans réveillent en nous ces peurs
ancestrales sinon comment comprendre que
devenus citoyens européens en janvier
2007 devons donc jouir en théorie des
mêmes droits que les autres citoyens
européens dont la liberté de circulation
et d'installation sur le territoire de
l'Union ils soit acculés envahir nos
bouches de métro ou à survivre
misérablement dans des campements qui
dshonorent notre pays les Romes ne sont
traités en France ni comme les autres
citoyens communautaires ni comme des
migrants non communautaires ce qui les
met en marge des dispositifs nationaux
de politique social or tous les
témoignages de terrain concordent ainsi
que la teste le rapport de l'ancien en
Alde les Romes roumains et bulgares
souhaitent rester résider chez nous de
manière stable et scolariser leurs
enfants lorsqu'ils sont régularisés ils
accèdent au logement et à l'emploi et
sortent de l'extrême
pauvreté si sous l'actuel gouvernement
leurs conditions d'accès au marché du
travail ont effectivement été assoupli
nous sommes toujours très loin du compte
monsieur le ministre chers
croyez-vous que les Romes émigrent chez
nous parce qu'ils sont heureux chez eux
les peuples heureux n'émigrent pas j'ai
vécu un moment il y a quelques années en
Europe centrale et je n'oublierai jamais
ces graves humaines etrant de nuit comme
de jour au bord des routes en
aillon je ne nirai pas que nous ayons
chez nous avec les Romes à faire face à
quelques abus ni la réalité des
désagréments causé au livrin par des
campements improvisés reste une vérité
amère sesome préfèrent la misère chez
nous à la persécution chez eux nos
tradition humanistes nous impose de
mettre fin à toute politique d'expulsion
de groupes ciblés à toute exclusion
spécifique de ces populations de nos
dispositifs éducatif sanitaires ou
sociaux elle nous impose au contraire
l'élaboration d'une politique veillant à
leur assurer un égal accès au droit ici
en même temps que d'une politique en
amont là-bas dans les pays d'origine
pour améliorer leurs conditions l'Europe
est notre
maison comme historienne comme juive et
comme citoyenne de ce pays je croyais
que la construction de l'Union
effacerait de notre vocabulaire à jamais
les mots de camp et de pogrom hélas avec
les Romes ces mots reviennent ils
s'entassent dans des campements de
fortune des riverins aux organisés
contre eux des sortes de
batus des milliers de pourtant des
milliers de visiteurs courant à
l'exposition la plus courue de ces
derniers jours qui s'intitule bohème de
Léonard de Vincy à Picasso au Grand
Palais parce que la bohème et les
bohémiens font partie du fantasme de
liberté
sans attach des artistes mais aussi du
Kidam mais on n'hésitera pas pour
chasser sans pitié une peau famille de
Rome parce que sa pauvreté sa saleté sa
condition sont une insulte à notre
confort mental quel décalage n'est-ce
pas 200000 ciganes d'Europe ont été
assassinés dans les camps de la mort à
nous d'accomplir notre juste travail de
mémoire en tant qu'Européen digne et de
montrer notre courage et en P
avançons la levée des mesures
transitoires ouvrons sans faillir
l'indispensable chantier de
l'intégration monsieur le ministre chers
collègues répondez sans tarder à l'appel
d'un devoir qui est celui du pays des
Droits humains que nous sommes anciens
et généreux creusés d'immigration
merci merci Madame Benbassa dernier
orateur inscrit Monsieur Pierre Charon
pour le groupe
UMP
monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre madame la
sénatrice mes chers
collègues je souhaiterit commencer mon
propos par des regrets bien que chacune
des interventions soit des plus
intéressantes la proposition de
résolution que nous examinons cet
après-midi ne nous laisse que très peu
de marge pour traiter le fond du sujet
madame archimo dans votre texte vous
pointez les nombreuses difficultés que
rencontrent certains ressortissants
bulgares et roumains lorsqu'ils viennent
en France que ce soit pour trouver du
travail pour se loger même pour se
soigner de même vous constatez la
précarité dans laquelle ils
vivent cette misère est insupportable
pour chacun d'entre nous les questions
de dignité humaine ne sont l'apanage
d'aucun parti politique madame la
sénatrice vous mentionnez plus
spécifiquement la précarité d'une
communauté celle des Romes à la lecture
du texte que vous nous proposez en tant
que parlementaire et républicain
permettez-moi de m'interroger lorsque
vous abordez les difficultés d'accès au
marché du travail français vous parlez
de ressortissant roumains et bulgares
mais ces difficultés tiennent au fait
qu'en tant que futur citoyens européens
ils doivent respecter les conditions
relatives aux mesures transitoires
inhérantes au processus d'adhésion des
des pays en phase d'intégration à
l'Union européenne ensuite vous abordez
les dispositifs de nos Mission Locale
d'Insertion les services des
collectivité pour le relogement de ces
personnes vous vous référez à une
origine ethnique et les désiger en tant
que Rome alors bien entendu vous nous
direz que cela est tout à fait différent
dans la mesure où vous vous prenez la
fin de la stigmatisation qui ne serait
propre qu'à la droite et que vous vous
exigez de l'État français et des
pouvoirs publics qu'il met tout en œuvre
pour que les gens puissent s'intégrer et
vivre décemment sur notre sol
national nous ne pouvons qu'être
d'accord avec vos propos à la seul
condition que nous abordions ce sujet
sans hypocrisie et sans malhonnêteté
intellectuelle en France avec le mot
Rome on parle de ressortissant de pays
d'Europe de l'Est le Conseil de l'Europe
lui regroupe dans une même définition je
cite les Romes les saintés les gens du
voyage et les groupes de population en
Europe il y a quelques minutes notre
collègue Pierre hisson a souligné les
dangers que sont les amalgames et la
confusion notamment avec les gens du
voyage en France pour ma part en tant
que républicain je ne peux que vous
renvoyer à l'article 1 de notre
Constitution la France est une
République indivisible laïque
démocratique et social elle assure
l'égalité devant la loi de tous les
citoyens sans distinction d'origine de
race ou de religion à croire qu'en
France nous sommes schizophrènes nous
voulons accueillir et intégrer tous ceux
qui souhait venir s'installer en France
peu importe le coût pour nos finances
déjà exang et nos concitoyens nous
parlons d'égalité et nous nous battons
tellement contre les discrimination que
nous devenons des égalitaristes forceés
mais nous avons cette manie de vouloir
sans cesse préciser l'origine des gens
aussi c'est en tant qu'élu de Paris que
je poursuis mon propos un élu de Paris
respectueux du droit communautaire et de
ses directives en particulier celle du
29 avril 2004 celle si stipule que pour
les séjours de moins de 3 mois le droit
de libre circulation et de séjour est
ouvert au ressortissant des étatsmembres
sans autres conditions qu'une carte
nationale d'identité ou d'un passeport
en cours de validité mais sous la
réserve du respect du droit public ce
droit n'est cependant maintenu que s'il
ne constitue pas je cite une charge
déraisonnable pour le système
d'assistance social de l'État membre
d'accueil alors dans ces conditions N
sont pas respectés non ces conditions ne
sont pas respectées et il n'est pas
scandaleux de vouloir faire abriquer le
dooit en tant qu'élu d'une ville parmi
les plus prestigieuses du monde visité
chaque jour par des dizaines de milliers
de touristes pour son histoire son
patrimoine et sa culture je suis atteré
de voir ce que Paris est en train de
devenir il s'agit maintenant pour les
touristes d'un véritable parcours du
combattant entre des groupes de pic
pocket organisés et des matelas servant
de couche à des familles à qui nous ne
pouvons pas offrir d'avenir on ne peut
se poser comme défenseur des droits de
l'homme et accepter ses conditions de
vie pour autant je vous mets au défi
d'expliquer à des familles qui
travaillent qui paient des impôts dont
la hausse est exponentielle à Paris que
vous allez attribuer des logements
sociaux prioritairement aux
ressortissants en situation
irrégulière de même alors que les
services de Pôle Emploi sont débordés
qui ne parviennent pas à recevoir les
demandeurs d'emploi déjà inscrits
vous irez leur expliquer que vous
souhaitez augmenter les flux de
migration européennes du travail parce
que c'est cela aussi la levée des
mesures transitoires même l'Espagne
pourtant exemplaire quant à
l'intégration des populations d'Europe
de l'Est et qui avait suspendu ces
mesures les a réintroduites le 22
juillet 2011 je m'insurge queon demeure
impuissant face aux actes de délinquence
qu'il soit commis par des ressortissants
bulgares ou roumains je suis effaré de
la fin de l'arrêté antimandicité qui
avait été mis en place le 14 septembre
2011 c'est la victoire du sectarisme sur
le droit à la sécurité en tant que
citoyen et élu parisien je m'insurge de
voir que l'on se déchaîne contre les
retours aux frontières de personnes qui
Bafou la Déclaration des Droits de
l'Enfant de 1959 en les contraignant à
la mendicité dans la rue ou dans Le
métrou Parisien ça et là je constate
qu'il est plus facile pour certains de
crier à la discrimination lors
d'expulsion plutôt que de voir la
tragique réalité qui n'est autre qu'une
double
instrumentalisation celle de la misère
et celle d'enfant à qui on vole leur
innocence à ce titre je vous renvoie aux
travaux de mes collègues Joë gomelam et
Isabelle Debré qui ont rendu des
rapports sur les mineurs roumains madame
la sénatrice je déplore votre manque de
réalisme et de
pragmatisme le propre du politique est
de prévenir d'anticiper et de
sauvegarder un bien précieux la cohésion
nationale l'impuissance et le laxisme
des autorités publiques quant aux
campements illégaux représentent une
menace pour la paix social l'érance de
ces ressortissants insupporte nos
concitoyens parce qu'ils ne comprennent
pas ce qui s'apparente à un mode de vie
et n'accepte pas de voir se développer
en bas de chez eux des bidonvilles cet
immobilisme retranché derrière le
misérabilisme est la source des pires
exactions il nourrit les extrêmes et
surtout conduit nos consultations
à agir en dehors du droit c'est la
société toute entière qui est en danger
l'incendie du campement à Marseille est
une double tragédie mettez-vous à la
chanson madame la société toute entière
est en danger l'incendie du campement à
Marseille est une double stratégie pour
la République française à que vous soyez
en désaccord avec ça ce geste n'a pas
été condamné à l'unanimité de la classe
politique c'est ulcérant et
antirépublicain comme l'a rappelé le
président mesard deuxièmement que des
habitants commettent un geste aussi
extrême qu'intolérable pour pasalier à
l'inertie des pouvoirs publics doit nous
alerter et nous faire constater que
c'est une fracture républicaine une
fracture républicaine dont nous sommes
tous responsables le peuple a tenté de
résoudre par lui-même un problème que
nous refusons de voir aussi si nous
continuons de détourner les yeux de la
réalité préférant le confort hypocrite
et les déclarations de bonnes intentions
comme votre proposition de résolution
nous détruirons ce qui reste de
confiance chez nos concitoyens en leur
République enfin et surtout il importe
que la France avec ses partenaires
européens engage un dialogue ferme et
responsable avec les gouvernements
bulgares et roumains ces deux étapes
bénéficient de fonds européens pour la
réintégration des Romes nous n pouvons
endosser cette responsabilité à leur
place l'Europe c'est l'union d'État qui
partage les mêmes valeurs mais c'est
l'union d'État responsable cap d'offrir
un avenir à leur peuple offrons à la
Bulgarie à la Roumanie cette occasion
formidable et nous nous substitons pas à
leurs devoirs nationaux je vous
remercie merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Alain Vidali
ministre chargé des Relations avec le
Parlement monsieur le président
Président Madame l'auteur de la
résolution mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et
sénatrices j'observe que le débat que
nous avons eu que vous avez eu a été un
débat
intéressant posé
calme évitant les extrêmes
jusqu'à la fin du débat et je le
regrette car d'une certaine façon on
voyait bien qu'elles étaient
éventuellement les réponses communes
consensuelles au moins républicaines qui
aurait pu sortir de cette discussion car
y compris certaines prises de position
ou certaines conclusions reposaient au
fond sur une conclusion qui n'était pas
très assise sur le raisonnement et je
pense que lorsque le
représentant du groupe usucr a dit que
au fond sur la question du travail de ce
que avait fait le gouvernement et de son
approche et que sur la question de la
formation professionnelle il pouvait il
y aurait pu y avoir un consensus je
pense que l'essentiel était fait et que
l'utilité de la démarche était é prouvée
à partir de là et montreit bien qu'on
pouvait sur cette question c'est
peut-être la bonne nouvelle de
l'après-midi dépasser les affrontements
habituels même si chacun a bien compris
que d'autres avaient une autre lecture
et essayer de recréer des frontières qui
n'avaient pas lieu d'être le Sénat
étudie aujourd'hui cette
proposition de résolution relative au
ressortissant de nationalités roumaines
et Bulgar je tiens naturellement d'abord
à excuser monsieur le ministre du
Travail de la formation professionnelle
et du dialogue social qui est en
déplacement à Marseille
aujourd'hui la loi constitutionnelle du
23 juillet 2008 a introduit dans notre
Constitution l'article 34-1 qui autorise
les assemblées à voter des résolutions
le vote des résolutions constitue une
des voies d'affirmation du Parlement lui
permettant d'exercer une expression
distincte de la réponse législative et
je crois que cette voix nouvelle
d'affirmation du rôle du Parlement est
une bonne chose le texte qui vous est
proposé par le groupe écologiste ce
texte fait référence à la situation des
Bulgares et des Romes et pour le dire
des Bulgares et des Roumains et pour le
dire très précisément pour l'essentiel
le débat l'a montré la situation des
Romes quand l'Europe a souhaité
s'acquitter de sa dette d'histoire
vis-à-vis des pays de l'Ouest et renoué
les fils de son histoire des fait par la
deuxème guerre mondiale puis la guerre
froide elle l'a fait dans des conditions
avec des conditions tant les écarts
entre nos pays et les derniers entrants
notamment dans l'Union européenne la
Roumanie et la Bulgarie était important
en matière de travail et d'emploi une
restriction à la libre circulation des
travailleurs roumains et Bulgar a été
décidé de manière
transitoire les travailleurs de ces deux
pays voulant exercer une activité
salariée en France sont soumis à une
autorisation de travail délivré par les
services de main-dœuvre étrangère dans
les conditions de droit commun
l'obtention de cette autorisation est
conditionné notamment notamment par la
situation de l'emploi qui leur est
opposable toutefois à l'origine une
liste de 150 métiers pour lequels la
situation de l'emploi n'était pas
opposable a été
établi
aujourd'hui nous portons cette
a été fait
hier à 291 métiers par souci de justice
et d'efficacité l'arrêté a été
publié pour éclairer le
débat notamment sur cet arrêté notamment
sur les commentaires politiques je veux
simplement signaler qu'il y a bien eu
une réaction à la publication de cet
arrêté que même ce qui ont indiqué
qu'ils allaientent s'abstenir sur la
résolution ont salué la seule réaction à
cet arrêté jusqu'à ce jour a été celle
de Marine Le Pen qui a considéré que cet
arrêté était parfaitement scandaleux que
chacun puisse se situer par rapport à
cette
réaction la liste élargie comprend
désormais tous les métiers situés
au-dessus d'un taux de tension de 0,6 ce
qui représente 72 % des offres d'emploi
de Pôle Emploi contre 46 % jusqu'à hier
le critère retenu est un critère
objectif correspondant à des secteur en
tension sur le marché de l'emploi il
place le curseur de notre point de vue
au bon endroit entre un chômage de masse
que l'on ne peut pas prendre la
responsabilité d'alimenter et des
tension
sectorielle le ministre du Travail a
souhaité consulter les partenaires
sociaux dans le cadre du comité du
dialogue social sur les questions
européennes et internationales au sujet
de cette liste élargie les directs ont
également été sollicité pour que cet
élargissement de la liste des métiers
soit soit enem prise avec la réalité du
terrain en parallèle et dans un souci de
justice nous avons voulu pas ajouter
l'entrave à la restriction la taxe du
par l'employeur lors de la délivrance du
titre de séjour et de son renouvellement
est d'ors et déjà supprimé à partir de
ce moment cette ouverture concerne 33000
roumains dont 26000 à â de travailler et
9000 bulgares dont 7000 à âge de
travailler parmi les autres pays de
l'Union 10 avaient choisi de n'appliquer
aucune une mesure de restriction dès
2007 C ont levé leurs restrictions en
2009 rejoints par l'Italie cette année
le dernier groupe de pays auquel
appartient la France s'est engagé dans
la voie de l'assouplissement des
contraintes la Belgique notamment
accélère la délivrance du permis de
travail par travailleurs roumain ou
Bulgar il ne faut pas entendre il ne
faudrait pas entendre spécifiquement le
Rome qui constitue une question
spécifique sur laquelle je vais revenir
gardons-nous de représentation trop
simple l'image du migrant affamé et
dépenaillé ne correspond pas toujours à
la réalité de ce que sont aujourd'hui la
majorité des migrations qui vont du
cadre supérieur à l'ouvrier des œuvré de
l'inggénieur qualifié au travailleur
spécialisés et l'un d'entre vous a
rappelé tout à l'heure et c'était une
bonne référence quand on parle des
migrations des travailleurs roumains il
y a beaucoup ici il y a beaucoup ici
d'élus locaux et nous passerions comme
ça je dirais du vendredi samedi dimanche
où on se bat dans nos territoires ruraux
pour faire venir des médecins roumains
au lundi où on se battrait ici pour
interdire aux Roumains de venir en
France je résume à peine mais c'est une
réalité qui est absolument partagée dans
deux rapports publiés sant vendredi 5
octobre par l' l'OCDE il est démontré
que 28 % des migrants par la migration
en général sont titulaires d'un d'un
diplôme supérieur contre 24 % pour les
nationaux les migrations sont donc un
accélérateur de compéten il faut savoir
les réguler mais aussi avoir pleinement
connaissance de leurs apports de plus
pour reprendre une formule qui a eu son
succès en France la France qui se lève
tôt est aussi largement composé de
travailleurs immigrés occupant des
emplois peu prisés par les Français j'en
viens à la question spécifique des Romes
contenue elle dans le cas des
travailleurs rouains et Bulgar car je
sais que la représentation nationale
attend du gouvernement une réponse sur
cette
question nous appartenons à une gauche
qui marche sur ces deux Jambles qui
n'ignore rien de la question de la
sécurité à ce titre l'évacuation des
campements Rome illicite se poursuivra
car la République suppose des règles à
commencer par le respect des décision de
justice il y a derrière ce sujet un vrai
enjeu de cohésion sociale la République
doit se transporter agir préserver
l'ordre public ou pour reprendre pied
quand elle s'est éclipsée mais nous
sommes
aussi la gauche du travail celle qui
pense qu'il est le meilleur moyen de
s'intégrer dans notre société d'en
partager les valeurs et les aspiration
c'est pourquoi nous en élargissons
l'accès sans pour autant peser sur le
chômage nous portons avec nous la
République qui ne dévie pas et qui n'est
pas
émiplégique qui croit au travail à
l'égalité et à l'insertion autant
qu'elle sait ce que sont l'autorité
l'ordre et la liberté si nous sommes les
successeurs de clémenenceo nous sommes
aussi ceux de jores et de la République
sociale l'une ne va pas sans l'autre le
rapport à la loi de caractère général de
la joi est un principe fondateur de la
République mais aussi un principe
protecteur
et je voudrais rappeler
ici un événement dans lequel nous avons
été quand nous étiz dans l'opposition
acteur et qui est l'application de ce
principe dans l'autre sens sur la
question de la situation des enfants
roumains en France il y a eu un
événement qui n'a pas été commenté mais
qui aurait dû être au cœur de nos débats
ou dans tous les cas être rappelé et qui
est l'accord intervenu entre le
gouvernement français et le gouvernement
roumain pour régler la question des
mineurs roumains isolé et des conditions
dans lesquelles nous devionions les
renvoyer dans leur pays
d'origine c'est un cas assez rare d'un
accord
ratifié sous les anciennes majorité du
Sénat et de l'Assemblée nationale et qui
a abouti tout simplement à une une
annulation par le Conseil
constitutionnel dans une date du dans
une décision du 4 novembre
2010 pourquoi le Conseil constitutionnel
avait-il annulé cet accord international
tout simplement parce que à l'époque la
majorité et le gouvernement en place au
nom de l'efficacité avait tout
simplement décidé que cela n'avait pas
droit au rôle protecteur de la loi dans
une disposition particulière où
s'agissant des enfants on avait décidé
que pour eux le le rôle
exclusivement attribué au juges des
enfants dans notre pays pour ces
enfants-l pour ces rom là serait de la
compétence du procureur de la République
qui sans référer à personne pourrait les
renvoyer comme ça dans leur pays c'était
l'accord signé par le gouvernement
français c'était l'accord ratifié par la
majorité de droite de l'époque au Sénat
par la majorité de droite de l'époque à
l'Assemblée nationale le Conseil
constitutionnel a rappelé à chacun que
lorsque dans ce débat et c'est naturel
on rappelle au Rome à d'autres qu'ici
c'est une république quiici on applique
la loi mais alors on la leur applique
mais ils ont aussi droit à bénéficier de
la loi c'est le cadre dans lequel
aujourd'hui se situe le gouvernement et
tout simplement le cadre
républicain en matière d'hébergement et
de logement pour les Romes l'ensemble
des outils existants est à mobiliser
depuis les dispositifs d'urgence
notamment pour les personnes les plus
vulnérables jusqu'à éventuellement la
mise en place de structures d'accueil
provisoir en lien avec les collectivités
territoriales en ce qui concerne les
dispositifs sociaux et sanitaires
d'accompagnement et de droits commun
ainsi que les questions de scolarisation
une mission interministériel a été
confié à plusieurs inspections pour
procéder à l'état des lieux des
dispositifs existants et au recensement
des expérimentations en cours et des
bonnes pratiques mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs je vous remercie d'abord
de la qualité du débat parce que vous
avez su ici au Sénat parler de ce sujet
difficile chacun ayant pu exprimer ses
arguments je remercie le groupe éc
d'avoir pris de nous avoir invité à ce
débat le gouvernement vous a donné sa
réponse avec une fil rouge qui est le
fil rouge de la réponse républicaine à
cette question sur le fond le
Gouvernement s'en remet à la sagesse du
Sénat pour l'approbation de cette
résolution je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues nous allons donc procéder au
vote sur la proposition de résolution et
je suis saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public de la part du groupe
UMP je vais donc procéder au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement ceux qui
souhaitent voter pour remettront au
secrétaire un bulletin blanc ceux qui
souhaitent voter contre un bulletin bleu
ceux qui souhaitent s'abstenir un
bulletin rouge le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est
ouvert
le scrutin est clos j'invite Mesdames et
Messieurs les secrétaire à procéder au
dépouillement du
scrutin
la
droite
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je vous donne donc lecture du résultat
du scrutin numéro 4 sur la proposition
de résolution relative au ressorti des
nationalités roumaines et bulgares
présenté en application de l'article 341
de la Constitution nombre de votants
344 nombre de suffrages exprimés 330 la
majorité absolu des suffrages exprimés
étant de
166 pour l'adoption
157 contre
163 le Sénat n'a donc pas adopté la
résolution
voilà pour l'examen de cette proposition
de résolution nous y reviendrons bien
entendu plus largement dans nos éditions
de 19h et de 22h très belle soirée à
tous le vrai courage il Lecler c'est pas
d'augmenter les impôts tout le le monde
le fa Nicolas SAR est parti mais la
crise est pas partie la politique
économique du gouvernement je lui
donnerai un zéro pointé tous les matins
à 8h15 Guillaume Durand et Gill Lecler
reçoivent une personnalité politique
dans l'invité politique reconstruire sa
crédibilité reconstruire sa popularité
il faut pas préjuger on peut juger après
en partenariat avec Radio Classique
l'invité politique tous les matins à
8h15 en direct sur public
SNA
depuis qu'elle est sénatrice du rhô la
centriste muguet Dini a fait de la lutte
contre les violence conjugale une
priorité une loi très attendue est votée
à l'unanimité en 2010 quel bilan peut-on
en faire 2 ans après sa mise en
œuvre